SPEAKER: Ever
opened up an invoice
from your Cloud
provider and been
surprised by what's inside?
Well, then this
video is for you.
Today, we're talking about
managing your Cloud costs
by exporting billing data
into your data warehouse
and analyzing it with Looker.
So let's jump in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Managing your billing
inside of the Cloud
can be a difficult task.
Most Cloud providers
employ a pay
for what you use model, which
means that if you're closely
monitoring usage
across services,
you can definitely save
on technology costs.
But if you don't have
centralized billing reporting
and have low visibility
into your Cloud spend,
unwanted or unknown spending
can really start to add up.
Additionally, each
Cloud provider
has their own billing
methodology, their own suite
of SKUs and services, and
their own way of reporting
that information back to you.
This means that as a
member of the FinOps team,
you might spend hours manually
centralizing, reconciling,
and harmonizing billing
across services and providers
each month, all to ask
a simple question like,
what did our marketing teams
cost us in Cloud Infrastructure
last quarter?
Well, don't worry.
Because, today, we're
going to walk through how
you can leverage Looker's Cloud
cost management solution to not
only control costs
for your organization,
but also reduced waste
and predictably forecast
both cost and resource needs.
So what makes Looker so
great to solve this problem?
Well, Looker is a business
intelligence platform
that sits directly on top
of your data warehouse,
giving business users
self-service access
to explore governed data.
This is all powered by Looker's
modeling layer, LookML.
With LookML, analysts can
define a single source of truth
for metrics used across
your organization.
And Looker goes
beyond traditional BI,
offering integrations
to deliver data
when and where you need it.
When it comes to
Cost Management,
Looker offers real-time insights
into Cloud spend and usage
so that Cloud users across
teams or cost centers
can better understand
and take action
to manage their
infrastructure spend.
So let's go ahead and dig into
the details of the solution.
This solution was
purposely designed
to be implemented in phases so
that you can start to get value
immediately and then
further customize it
based on your initial findings.
So the first phase
includes access
to Looker Blocks, or pre-built
LookML models and dashboards
that can be installed
in just a few clicks
from the marketplace on
your Looker instance.
In fact, we've created
three different blocks,
one for each major
Cloud provider,
so that you can pick and choose
which you want to leverage,
depending on what
providers you use.
In this phase, the billing
data for each provider
stays inside of that Cloud.
So you connect Looker to
Amazon Web Services billing
data that has been
exported into Athena,
Azure billing data into
Azure SQL warehouse,
and Google Cloud billing
data into BigQuery.
Additionally, this block
uses Booker's ability
to merge query results from
different data warehouses
to create a unified
dashboard showing you
spend across all three clouds.
So now you might be wondering,
what do these blocks actually
do for me?
Let's take a deeper
look at how a FinOps
team might use phase one of the
Cloud cost management solution.
In phase one,
you're given access
to a set of dashboards
for each Cloud.
For example, here you can
see dashboards for Google.
Let's start with a
summary view where
you can see at a high level
where your organization is
spending on GCP.
From here, you can drill into
specific projects or products,
like Compute Engine, where
we seem to be spending a lot.
Google Cloud also offers
tactical recommendations
for limiting cost.
For example, here we can see
that if we stop this idle VM,
we can save close to $900.
To directly implement
this change,
we can simply click
here to go directly
to that page in the
Google Cloud console.
Also in phase one,
you get access
to a simple dashboard
that shows you
spend across all of these clouds
using Looker's merged results
feature.
Here you can get an
idea for how spend
compares across providers.
With phase one, you jumpstart
your Cloud cost management with
out-of-the-box reporting.
And if you're only
heavily using one Cloud,
it might be suitable for
your longer-term needs,
but there are some limitations
to this approach primarily
because of the data
that's siloed in provider
specific data warehouses.
In phase two, companies work
with Looker and partners
to centralize data in BigQuery
so that all Cloud Billing
information is stored
in a central location.
Phase two allows you to ask
deeper questions of your data
because billing SKUs
and services are
harmonized across providers.
So instead of looking
at macro trends
like total spend
for each provider,
you can drill in
to see specifics.
For example, if you're spending
more on machine learning,
specifically on Google,
Amazon, or Microsoft.
So let's take a look.
In phase two, we go beyond the
original multicloud report.
Because data from each Cloud is
centralized into a single data
warehouse, you're
able to compare
spend across specific
services and SKUs,
like we're showing here.
For example, we can focus
on spend for Compute
across all three providers.
Centralizing your Cloud
Billing data into BigQuery
unlocks even more
cost-saving opportunities.
But in the last
phase, we take things
one step further
by mapping tags,
labels, and call
center information
across each of the clouds.
Additionally, we introduce
automatic data actions
and BigQuery machine
learning forecasting models
to empower you to be proactive
about spending decisions
and take direct action
from within the tool.
Let's see how that empowers
users to further optimize
spend.
With phase three, you're
given much more power
to act on cost insights.
Now, with cost center
mappings customized
for your organization,
you can do things
like leverage machine
learning models
to estimate future spend
for specific business areas.
So instead of needing
to manually create
invoices in Excel, Looker
will send a document
with each line item to
the appropriate director
on your behalf.
Awesome.
So now you should
have an understanding
of how Looker gives
FinOps teams the ability
to save money and reduce waste
for Cloud Infrastructure.
Through this phased
approach, you
can start optimizing
right away, and then
continue to customize
and integrate insights
to further support
your organization.
Ready to get started?
Check out the links below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]